dr. Anthony foul a head of the National
Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Diseases and kind enough to join us doc
can we start with the official height
and weight first of all I agree with you
I love walking on trails but not
sleeping okay I'm I'm actually I was
five seven until I started five six
hundred forty nine pounds all right who
plays basketball the way you played
basketball in high school give us a
comparison here you know there isn't any
and that's that you know I was
commiserating with some of the people
who now that I'm pretty visible where
ball plays and talking about the style
of thing back then was really a long
time ago was the two handed set shot a
lot of fast breaks a lot of driving and
picks when the two-handed set shot went
out of style and everything was stop and
jump then if you didn't have the height
to jump over somebody you were in
serious trouble that's when I decided I
wanted to be a physician and a scientist
I always found out and I always say that
I was a very fast good shooting point
guard that was five seven and when a
very fast good shooting point five seven
goes against the very fast good shooting
point guard who's six three it's over
when's the last time you spoke to a
commissioner just you know must have
been a couple of days ago because
obviously there's a lot of interest and
and I was impressed with the sincerity
of people of trying to get the sport
back and do it in a way that's safe for
the players but also when you think
about can you or can you not get
spectators in the sense of people in the
audience how do you do that safely it's
not gonna be easy
you know particularly depending on the
sport that you're talking about but I
was impressed by the leadership of the
league's
being sincerely interested in making
sure that people are safe at the same
time they get their sport going what's
your biggest concern right now with with
what's going on with the respective
boards and how they are playing or how
they're preparing to play well you know
if you create and these these bubbles
that people are talking about where you
essentially test all the players
essentially sequester them isolate them
make sure that people who come into
contact with them are are clearly
following the strictest rules you can do
a sport be it a non-contact mostly
non-contact sport like baseball which
has some contact but not a lot
versus a very context point like
football that you can do it but you
likely would have to be doing it in a
way where it essentially gets televised
I have found which was interesting that
many of the players really are balking
at the idea about being completely
sequestered understandably so from their
families for a period of time because
once you get a player that's infected
even though as a young healthy person it
might not be of any you know major
impact to that person there's still a
danger that some young people we're
starting to see now are having serious
consequences so you got to protect the
health of the player when you get one
player infected and you're in a context
for it then you really have to have the
decision what do you do now with the
people who become in contact with him
and that's the real question because
under non sports circumstances what you
would do is that when you get those
people and you would essentially
quarantine or sequester them for a
certain number of days the trouble isn't
a sport if you do that you're gonna
quickly fall apart once a couple of
people and yet because you get half the
team is gonna so you got to figure out a
way how you can keep the game going
without sacrificing or risking the
health of the players would that mean
following them carefully and testing
them every day when a person becomes
positive pull them out you know I don't
know quite yet how that's gonna work out
it's not gonna be easy
it's not gonna be easy it's the NFL
naively optimistic here doc you know I
don't want to call
them naive because I think they're
working hard I'm trying to get something
to work I know that they're trying their
best to be cautiously optimistic
again you have to weigh what you're
talking about are you talking about
getting a sport going that can be
observed even in a situation where a lot
of parts of the country are being
restricted in their physical contact
mainly you're not going to have people
sitting in the stands close to each
other
sneezing and coughing on each other
that's gonna be a problem if you can get
away with either televised completely or
a very serious social distancing will
you limit severely the number of people
that come into a stadium or an arena or
a basketball arena I'm Joe I look at it
and I know that the NFL if it feels like
it's full speed ahead
like hey nothing's gonna stand in our
way you know college football it feels
the same way I underwent er I I don't
know where you stand on that but your
thoughts on can we have an abbreviated
season and does that make more sense you
know it does Diana there's been some
serious discussions about that in fact I
was just asked about that no longer than
two days ago and the question that was
asked obviously if the standpoint of a
respiratory illness gets more intense as
you get into the fall and the winter
could you have a baseball season where
the so-called world series of playoffs
don't go past that mid-september
so you have a truncated season you go
July August get your games in have a
pennant series and you're done rather
than do what we do we are into late
October for the last game of the series
which is right in the middle of the not
the middle but the beginning of not only
the influenza season but if you're gonna
get a second wave which I hope we don't
get a second wave in the winter and we
do something to prevent that you still
increase the risk so the idea about
creatively manipulating the the
timeframe of the season is something
that should be considered
I don't Dan have a receiver of an answer
to it if it was an easy answer the smart
people who run the league's could have
figured that out a long time ago it's
got to really be seriously considered
the pros and the cons our pro athletes
less at risk they are not less at risk
of getting infected as young healthy
people and you look at the history now
we got a lot of history now you know we
have two million cases in this country
and over 220,000 deaths when you look at
that although there are exceptions and
young people for no other reason have
gotten seriously ill and died from this
for the most part
young healthy people do very well they
do some gets sick enough to keep them in
bed for a week or two or more others get
mild symptoms just for a short period of
time but when you compare I mean for an
example the risk of a healthy young
football baseball basketball hockey
soccer player of getting into trouble
compared to me at my age with some
comorbidity conditions dramatically
different I am at much much much more of
a higher risk than a 25 year old or a 24
year old athlete not zero risk for that
person it's it's less it's certainly
risk of getting infected because there's
no it's it's equal opportunity in
getting infected
it's how sick you get and I think then
that's one of them is one of the
confusing aspects of this disease and
why people say why is some people
getting so excited about it and why are
people not even caring about it is
that's the only infection that I've ever
dealt with and I've been doing this for
now
over 40 years well you got some people
to get infected in 20 to 40 to 50
percent don't even know they're infected
they have no symptoms then you get
something get mild symptoms they feel a
little achy but nothing big deal then
others feel sick enough to stay go to
bed others are in bed for two to three
weeks some require hospitalization some
require intensive care and then some die
so I mean when you have such a broad
spectrum it gets confusing about how
seriously you should take it I think the
entire population Dan needs to take it
seriously because we're all in it
together so even though as a young
healthy person might be minimally
impacted from a physical standpoint that
person can easily continue to propagate
the outbreak in the country by spreading
it to someone who spreads it to someone
who then spreads it to a vulnerable
person your grandmother my my uncle
who's got a condition that's bad and
then all of a sudden you get into
trouble so you have to have a
responsibility not only to yourself
because you want to preserve your own
health but the fact that you're a part
of a community and as part of the
community if you don't care about
getting infected you should care about
the possibility that you're spreading it
to somebody else
and that propagates the outbreak that
we're all trying to stop how surprised
are you that you haven't gotten it you
know I'm not surprised because first of
all I deal in the White House virtually
every day so you don't walk into the
White House unless you're negative so
that everybody in the White House is
negative so the only time you're gonna
see me outside of where I am now is in a
building but maybe can can hold a few
thousand people there five people in the
building and I have me and my tech guy
who's clearly 10 feet away who's
allowing us to do this when I go home
whenever I'm outside I wear a mask all
the time um in my house my wife is
negative
she's not infected obviously because
she's been with me for so long and
that's it my life is very limited dan
I'm in here doing my job trying to
develop a vaccine and drugs I'm spending
time at the White House trying to get
the public health policy right and I see
questa myself so I'm not surprised that
I'm not infected but if I were out there
in the bars or you know making out
there's nothing wrong i I would be at a
high risk of getting into trouble
forget sports here for a moment if he
will doctor would you send your child to
school this fall
good question Dan and and I'm glad you
asked it in that way because you've got
to determine where in the United States
you are and what the dynamics of the
infection are in the state city town
county where you're at we tend to think
of the United States uni-dimensional II
when you say would you Center your child
to school well if I were in a County
where there were virtually no infections
and there was not a lot of issue I would
have no trouble sending my child to
school if I were in a place that was
having still really active increases in
infections I would be very concerned if
I were in a place that was intermediate
where there were infections but they
were reasonably well controlled a lot of
the schools in a creative way allow kids
to come back here's some options that
not only have been discussed but I think
are gonna be implemented change the
schedule the way we were talking about
the sports have some kids come in on
Monday morning clean up the place have
other group come in on Monday afternoon
or alternate days all day Monday clean
up on Tuesday all day Wednesday clean up
on Thursday that kind of thing or you
can have classrooms that instead of
those desks that are right near each
other you can separate it by the amount
have kids wear masks in school maybe
have some of the classes outside when
you have children with underlying
conditions like diabetes or a heart
condition make sure they have the
capability of
doing a virtual class online these are
all creative ways but again it gets back
to where you are are you in an area with
a lot of infections or are you in an
area with very few infections you work
with Ronald Reagan George H Bill Clinton
George W Barack Obama now Donald Trump
if you could sit down and have a beer
socially with any of those you know they
all have different approaches I got to
know some better than others you know
that I would say I wouldn't mind having
to be with all of them but politics
though no no how many of you had a beer
with um you know I I would say I had a
beer where they didn't person that I
that I that I spent a lot of time I
spent a lot of time with with with with
with several of them not so much with
Reagan
but clearly with George HW Bush with
with George W Bush with Clinton with
Obama but the the opportunity that I
have had to have meals and dinner were
really with the bushes I've had dinners
with at the White House and and when he
was vice president with George HW Bush I
like George H I he's one of the finest
human beings you'll ever want to meet
George W Bush also a great guy he
doesn't drink as you know so I drink
beer and eat you know have a
non-alcoholic beer at a dinner but
George HW Bush I mean a real a real fine
fine fine gentleman can you all they all
have their good points can you say this
publicly just so I can play it for my
wife that drinking beers is okay for you
like if you say it's okay then I'm good
I will tell your wife that it's okay for
you then go for it how many though doc
is is it just one yeah
no no you've really got to be careful
because there is you know a certain
amount of drinks that they
say for a man versus a women a woman can
tolerate less than a man
I mean tolerate from the standpoint of
health I'm not talking about holding
your liquor as it were no you should not
you should not have more you know then
thence then you know seven drinks
it shouldn't binge drink you should have
no more than than one or two beers I
mean when you start going to three four
or five then you're talking about
binging and that's bad but you know a
bear a beer once a day one in the
evening a glass of wine isn't that is
fine I hope you're well and thank you
for all that you've been doing doctor
and thank you for being available for
people to be able to ask you questions
it's it's a great public service and we
appreciate your time well thank you for
giving me the opportunity I appreciate
it myself
that's doctor fountain